هكذا قضت دول منتدى اسيا والمحيط الهادي
افك في بيانهم الختاميه ان معظمهم يدينون
هذه الحرب من روسيا على اوكرانيا وقال قضت
الدول الاعضاء في المنتدى وبينها روسيا
والصين ان معظم الاعضاء دانوا بشده الحرب
في اوكرانيا وشددوا على انها تسببه معاناه
انسانيه هائله وتؤدي الى تفاقم نقاط الضعف
الحاليه في الاقتصاد العالمي وتتسبب في
تقيد النمو وزياده تضخم وتعطيل سلاسل
توريد وتعمق من انعدام امن الطاقه
وبالغذاء وتزيد من مخاطر الاستقرار
الماليه واشار البيان الى انه كانت هناك
راء اخرى وتقيمات مختلفه للوضعي والعقبات
معنا من العاصمه تايلنديه بانكوك مراسل
الجزيره صهيب جاسم اذا لدينا خطوط عريضه
في ما يتعلق بالبيان الختامي بالاضافه الى
ذلك اللقاء مع كمال هاريس و الرئيس الصيني
كيف بدل بيان ختامي وما ابرز ما تم نقاشه
في هذا اللقاء
بياتي بعد ايام من مياده بعد ايام من
القمه التي جماعه الرئيس الصيني سجن بينج
والرئيس الامريكي هي اول القمه بين
البلدين منذ تسلم الرئاسه وربما هذه اول
ايضا اول ماراثون دبلوماسي للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في جنوب شرق اسيا وكذلك
للرئيس شريف بنفسه بعد اربع سنوات من
انقطاعا او ثلاث سنوات او اربع سنوات من
انقطاعم عن كثير من الاجتماع
هذا الاجتماع الاول منذ اربع سنوات لم يكن
المهم فقط في هذه اجتماعات هي ما ما صدر
من البيانات انما لقاءات الثنائيه كانت
مهمه وبايغه الاهميه
اجتماعات اخرى بين رئيس
الامريكيه وهمم رئيس الوزراء التايلندي
وكذلك رئيس الوزراء يجتمع بالرئي فهو
تدافع واضح في الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
والصينيه في المنطقه لاحظناه في اسيان
ولاحظ ما هو في قمه العشرين في بالي
ونلاحظه اليوم هنا في هذه الايام منذ ايام
حتى هذا اليوم هنا في تايلاند واضح ان
البيان التي ذكر
تفضلت بذكره مياده في المقدمه هذه الفقره
جاءت تقريبا يعني متطابقه مع الفقره
الاتجاهات في بيان قمه ال 20 هذه الفقره
من 167 كلمه
والبيان الذي في قمه العشرين من 170 كلمه
فرق فرق فقط اربعه كلمات بين نفس الفقره
التي تتحدث عن الحرف في اوكرانيا بشكل
لافتت جدا لاحظه كثير من الصحفيين
والمراقبين كيف ان الفقره هي نفس الفقره
تتحدث عن ادانه الحرف في اوكرانيا وفي نفس
الوقت تشير الى وجود اراء مختلفه طبعا
حضور روسيا هنا في ايبك بوجود نائب رئيس
الوزراء وكذلك حضور روسيا هناك في قمه
العشرين ربما دفع الى وضع هذه العباره
وايضا الى اعتراض كثير من الدول الاسيويه
من بينها الهند و اندونيسيا والصين هناك
وهنا الصين وروسيا بشكل واضح اعتراضهم على
العقوبات على روسيا واضح ان اللقاءات
الثنائيه كما نعود الى اللقاء الثنائي
اللقاء الثنائي الذي كان اليوم بين حارس
كان لقاء محمد رغم انه مختصر وكاله
الانباء الصينيه قالت ايضا تاكيد اني ما
ذكرتموه انه عبر الرئيس الصيني عن امله
بان تعزز بلاده ولايات المتحده التفاعل
متبادل وان يقلل من سوء التفاهم والاحكام
الخاطئه وان تعني يعمل البلدان لارجاع
العلاقات الى مسارها الصحيح والمستقر
ونقلت الوكاله ايضا عن على عن حارس قولها
انها قالت للرئيس الصيني ان بلادها لا
تريد مواجهه ولا صراعا مع الصين وانها انه
يجب ان يتعاون البلدان ويبقيان قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه بينهما هذه الرسائل
ايجابيه من ناحيه ولكن من ناحيه اخرى هناك
يتدافع واضح بين القوى هنا في هذه المنطقه
وهذا ما يشرح ما ما يفسر لنا عدم التوصل
الى اتفاق ما يتعلق باتفاق اتجاه الحره في
هذه المنطقه حيث اشار البيان الختامي الى
انه وضعت خطه زمنيه لعده سنوات تستمر
لمناقشه الوصول الى اتفاق تجاره حره بين
الدول المنطقه وهذا امر صعب وليس سهل حيث
ان هناك مبادرات اخرى كاننا نتحدث عن اسيا
والمحيط الهادي
ولكن ضمن هذه الدائره الكبيره هناك دوائر
اخرى الصين لديها مشروعها واليابان لديها
مشروعها الذي يتناغم مع المشروع الامريكي
المتعلق بالاطار الاقتصادي لمنطقه اسيا
لمنطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وهي وهو
وهو اطار اوسع فقط اليس فقط المحيط الهادئ
ولكن المحيط الهندي ايضا وبالتالي هناك
تدافع من جهه وهناك سعي للوصول الى
توافقات فيما يتفق مع المصالح المشتركه
للجميع خاصه في الملفات الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه والكل مترابط اقتصاديا وبحريا
ولذلك لا يمكن ان ان ان ان يتغافل اي من
هذه الاقتصادات هذه الاقتصادات الكبرى في
المنطقه عن اقتصاد دوله اخرى
العاصمه التايلنديه بانكوك مراسله الجزيره
صهيب جاستن شكرا جزيلا لك